Chad de nouveaux otages un Suisse et un
Français les rebelles réclament un
milliard de centimes à la France la
fédération de l'éducation nationale
réclame la nationalisation de
l'enseignement invité de notre journal
André hen michelatovski révèle en cas de
victoire de la gauche les communistes
veulent 7 ministères et tr secrétariat
d'État les Français et la violence un
plus grand besoin de sécurité malgré une
baisse de
criminalité Madame Mademoiselle Monsieur
bonsoir il s'appelle Christian mass et
André Pierre kumerling le premier est
français le second est de nationalité
suisse et tous deux depuis dimanche sont
prisonniers des maquisars du frolina au
Tchad pour la libération de ces deux
hommes le frolina demande des rançons de
milliards de francs partiellement en
équipement militaire il exige en outre
le départ des troupes françaises qui se
trouvent actuellement au Tchad depuis
dimanche la France et la Suisse se
trouvent donc confrontés à ce que l'on
pourrait appeler une nouvelle affler
Claustre et le Tchad lui se trouve
confronté à une extension semble-t-il
importante de la rébellion dans ce pays
madame Claustre avait été enlevé au
Tibesti c'est-à-dire dans l'extrême nord
du Tchad ici presque à la frontière
libyenne le DC3 de l'armée tchadienne
qui s'est écrasé qui a été abattu
dimanche avec trois militaires français
à bord est tombé à 800 km de la capitale
njamena au sud de ce massif le frolina
annonce également qu'il encercle
actuellement fa largeot au centre de la
région borcou etedit Tibesti ici et
enfin les deux hommes enlevés dimanche
l'ont été non loin de la capitale
tchadienne près du lac Tchad ici
exactement la rébellion semble donc ces
derniers temps et depuis quelques mois
prendre une extension importante faire
Tach d'huile sur l'ensemble du
territoire tchadien 2 ans donc après
laaffire
clustre cette prise d'otage serait donc
le deuxième coup du frolina en moins
d'une semaine dimanche dernier en effet
c'est un DC3 piloté par trois
sous-officiers français qui était abattu
non loin de fill àargeot selon le
frolina il n'y aurait pas eu de
survivant apparemment c'est donc une
véritable offensive contre la France et
contre le Tchad bien sûr que vient de
lancer le Front de libération nationale
du Tchad Paris étant accusé d'aider le
régime de damena dans sa lutte contre la
rébellion tchadienne ce que l'on sait
sur le frelina c'est que ce mouvement
est révolutionnaire anti-impérial et qui
lutte pour renverser Félix Maloum le
président du
Tchad la Libye est aujourd'hui le pays
qui soutient le plus activement la
rébellion tchadienne Tripoli fourniré au
frolina du matériel de fabrication
soviétique c'est par la Libye que les
guerrierséros sont en contact avec
l'extérieur l'intérêt du colonel Kaddafi
dans cette histoire une bande de
territoire à la frontière tchadlibienne
la bande d'Ozu riche en phosphate et en
pétrole on peut remarquer enfin c'est
que le frolina n'était pas responsable
de l'affaire clustre l'ethnologue du
CNRS avait été enlevé par les rebelles
tbou d' cenabé or celui-ci n'avait
jamais voulu fusionner avec le frolina
mieux à sa libération Françoise clostre
avait assuré que le frolina était une
organisation politico-mitaire qui ne
prenait jamais d'otage il reste ce soir
qu'un Français et un Suisse se trouvent
aux mains de ce mouvement et Paris a
jusqu'au 12 février pour répondre à
l'ultimatum du frolina une dernière
précision monsieur André kumerling le
Front de Libération donc du chchad le
frolina a annoncé aujourd'hui détenir en
otage depuis dimanche est un monteur
électricien de 27 ans qui est originaire
d'nex près de Genève en Suisse on ignore
pourquoi il se trouvait actuellement au
Tchad puisque sa mère que lafp l'Agence
France Press a pu joindre au téléphone
nous a appris que son fils travaillait
au Cameroun habituellement et qu'il se
trouvait au chchad depuis quelques jours
en vacances semble-t-il il ne s'agit
donc pas en aucun cas de correspondant
ou de coopérants
militaires dans le feu de la campagne
électorale française certaines
informations vous en doutez ont tendance
à passer au second plan pourtant
certaines d'entre elles conditionnent la
vie de centaines de milliers de Français
le cas s'est produit cette semaine avec
l'échec à Bruxelles des négociations
européennes sur le droit de pêche
l'affaire n'est pas simple comme tous
les dossiers européens d'ailleurs et but
sur le refus britannique
de d'accepter disons les nouvelles
conventions de pêche pour l'Europe
chaque pays se retrouve donc face à ces
problèmes pour les Français c'est le
sort de milliers de pêcheurs qui se joue
actuellement
d'où vient le poisson qui est vendu ce
matin à concarne mais ce matin monsieur
sur qure chalutiers à la vente nous en
avons trois qui viennent de la région
Ouest Écosse c'estàdire c'està-dire des
EAU territorial anglais ces navires ont
travaillé certainement en dehors des
12000 mais en dedans des 12 à 50000
anglais les pêcheurs de Concarneau et
bien d'autres vivent sous une épée de
damoclaise les Anglais ne vont-ils pas
d'un jour à l'autre leur interdire
directement ou indirectement d'aller
pêcher là où ils attrapent 60 % de leur
prise c'est-à-dire essentiellement dans
la zone comprise entre 12 et 50000 entre
20 et 90 km des côtes anglaises et aussi
des côtes irlandaises si demain nous ne
pouvions plus exercer dans les zonees
considéré ça voudrait dire en clair que
quantité de bateau seraiit arrêté et
quand nous savons que
quin marin
pêcheur produit trois emplois indu soit
en aval ou en amont de la
pêche ça représenterait quelques 20 ou
25000 chômeurs rien qu'en cornouail si
on peut plus aller là oigé de se
rabattre sur la pêche artisanale alors
ça va pas durer longtemps et puis la
pêche va être supprimée entièrement quoi
rester quoi je suis patron de pêche
depuis une dizaine d'années et j'étais à
l'école je voudrais bien conserver mon
métier au lieu de de mon ailleur
quoi la délégation française à Bruxelles
à hubo avec ses se autres partenaires
proposer aux Anglais des compromis
offrir de limiter les prises dans les
eaux anglaises s'engager à des mesures
de conservation très poussées le
ministre anglais monsieur silkin est
resté intransigeent alors dans les ports
breton à l'inquiétude tente à s'ajouter
maintenant une froide
détermination il est impensable
que positions anglaises soient retenu et
que nous soyons évincés de ces lieux de
pêche du reste nous demandons
aujourd'hui à nos marins pêcheurs de
continuer à pratiquer sur les lieux de
pêche qu'ils ont l'habitude de
fréquenter et il appartient au
gouvernement français de prendre ses
dispositions pour tout mettre en œuvre
quant à la défense de nos
pêcheurs alors la guerre du poisson pour
demain des canonnières pour escorter les
pêcheurs bretons dans les eaux anglaises
on n' est pas là mais l'amertume est
mauvaise conseillère et sur nos côtes en
ce moment le marché commun n'a pas le
vent en
poupe la politique avec les multiples
déclarations de cette journée la
naissence d'un nouveau cle aussi tout
d'abord l'UDF ou Union pour la
démocratie française sous ce sigle vont
se regrouper pour aller au combat
électoral les candidats du CDS du Parti
radical et du parti républicain
autrement dit depuis aujourd'hui la
majorité est effectivement divisé en
deux grands courants le courant Gauliste
sous la bannière du RPR et le courant
giscardien sous l'étandard de l'UDF les
déclarations donc de cette journée elles
tournent toutes ou presque autour des
propos que tenait hier soir George
Marchet sur Antenne 2 réaction
socialiste d'abord par la voix de
Monsieur Michel Rocard à l'affirmation
du leader communiste selon laquelle le
Parti socialiste repousserait à 1980 la
mise en œuvre des grandes réformes de
structure selon Michel Rocard le Parti
socialiste engagera immédiatement après
les élections ses réformes de structure
il faut faudra partir tout de suite dit
Michel Rocard mais suffisamment
habilement pour que le Conseil
constitutionnel soit obligé de les
ratifier quant à Monsieur Michel
poniatovski il est revenu aujourd'hui
avant de prononcer un important discours
à Nant sur la participation de ministre
communistes au gouvernement de la
gauche il semble bien que la demande du
Parti communiste se réfire comme l'a dit
Monsieur Marchet en effet à Sep
ministères c'est la demande minimum et
trois secrétariats d'État alors quels
sont ces ministères d'abord un des trois
grands ministères l'intérieur les
affaires étrangères ou la défense
nationale ensuite la production
industrielle et les entreprises
nationalisées le ministère du Travail le
ministère de la Sécurité sociale et de
la famille le ministère de la Jeunesse
et des Sports et nous arrivons ensuite à
trois ministères qui sont découpés
l'intérieur les communistes réclame les
collectivités locales et l'aménagement
du territoire le ministère des Finances
les communistes réclam les services
économiques le plan et puis le dernier
ministère divisé c'est la défense
nationale où les communistes réclament
comme en 1946 le le
l'armement dernière demande le
secrétariat d'État à l'enseignement
supérieur vous voyez que c'est ce sont
des demandes qui correspondent au
contrôle de l'économie au contrôle des
services sociaux et au contrôle de
l'appareil de l'État et des
collectivités locales qu'est-ce qui vous
permet d'affirmer tout ce que vous venez
de dire d'abord je ne parle jamais à la
légère et ensuite quand un débat de
cette importance s'ouvre nécessairement
les échos en arrivve à ceux qui se
trouvent concernés par la chose
politique conséquence de l'incertitude
politique du moment le franc connaît
depuis hier une chaude alerte la Banque
de France a dû intervenir aujourd'hui
pour soutenir notre monnaie 60 millions
de dollars ainsi que des Deutsch Mar
auraiit été vendu cela n'a pas suffi et
le franc a perdu en quelques heures près
de 2 % le dollar est monté à 4 francs 83
contre 4 franc 74 hier tandis que le
franc suisse devient quasiment
inabordable à 2 franc 44 on serra demain
si cette chute continue monsieur rayond
bar à sa sortie de l'Élysée il y a
quelques minutes a d'ailleurs expliqué
la baisse du franc par des facteur
psychologique nous voyons apparaître ici
a dit le Premier ministre les
conséquences de l'incertitude politique
an Nant la politique a cédé le pas
aujourd'hui à la revendication
strictement syndicale le Congrès de la
Fédération de l'éducation nationale se
poursuit mais le grand débat celui qui
oppose au sein même de la feine
socialiste et communiste s'est terminé
par la victoire disons de la tendance
socialiste le passage un passage du
discours de Monsieur André Henri annonce
d'ailleurs bien la couleur si le Parti
communiste refusait au second tour de se
désister pour la gauche il porterait
devant l'histoire la responsabilité
d'avoir donné la victoire à la droite a
déclaré sous les applaudissements du
Congrès le secrétaire général de la f
André Henri vous êtes avec nous ce soir
en direct vous êtes à Nant bien sûr
puisque ce congrès se tient à Nant il
semble bien que sous un habit syndical
on est surtout à Nant parler politique
c'est la saison à votre avis qui veut
cela pas du tout je crois que c'est
exagéré de dire que à Nant nous avons
parlé politique ce sont les différentes
tendances les différents courants du
mouvement syndical qui se sont exprimé
et je crois que ce qui a dominé en
définitive le Congrès de Nantes c'est la
volonté d'un dépendance qui pourrait en
être étonné mais l'indépendance de la f
n'a jamais été un apolitisme desséchant
et il est clair que dans cette période
personne n'aurait compris si la FA ne
s'était pas exprimée sur la situation
politique économique et sociale du
moment nous avons procédé une analyse
critique extrêmement fouillée de la
politique du pouvoir qui est contraire
aux intérêts des travailleurs et
particulièrement contraire aux intérêts
de la Jeunesse et aux intérêts des
travailleurs de l'éducation de la
recherche et de la culture que nous
représentons et de la même façon nous
avons dit au Parti de la Gauche qu'il
fallait tout faire pour que demain la
victoire soit remportée et nous avons
demandé que chacun joue le jeu des
descistement réciproque c'est vrai que
si l'un des partis de la gauche prenait
la responsabilité de refuser le
dessistement comme a menacé de le faire
le Parti communiste français et bien il
porterait une très lourde responsabilité
voilà ce que nous avons dit à N mais sur
un rapport Mor parle de 80 pages il y en
avait deux consacrés à ce sujet André
Henri il y a quand même deux courants de
pensée deux grands courants de pensée à
l'intérieur de la fédération de
l'éducation nationale l'un est
majoritaire c'est le courant disons
socialisant l'autre est minoritaire
c'est le courant communisant comment
finalement arrivez-vous à rester uni le
congrès de Nant est le congrès du 30e
anniversaire de l'unité maintenue et
renforcée de la fête par conséquent nous
sommes habitués à des confrontations à
des débats difficiles parfois un petit
peu passionnés je crois qu'il ne faut
pas confondre les cours courant de pensé
syndicaux qui sont l'expression
naturelle de la démocratie et puis les
fractions une fraction c'est
effectivement une tendance qui prend
nature qui prend racine dans le courant
politique et qui tient sa sensibilité
propre de la sensibilité d'un parti
politique il n'en est rien à la feine
même si dans la tendance unité et action
se retrouvent principalement les
militants communistes je peux dire que
dans la majorité nationale de la
celle-ci est d'esprit socialiste
d'esprit de cœur socialiste mais le
nombre de militants qui ont la carte du
parti est sans doute assez petit mais
Monsieur André Henri si au lendemain des
élections après une victoire de la
gauche il y a un ministre de l'éducation
qui est communiste quelle sera votre
réaction vis-à-vis de ce ministre que le
ministre de l'éducation nationale demain
soit communiste radical de gauche ou
socialiste ça sera pas la même chose
tout de même ou qu'il soit de droite si
la droite l'emporte le secrétaire
général de la FEN défendra les mandats
du Congrès de Nantes quel que soit le
résultat de l'échéance politique de mars
78 nos priorités ne changeront pas de
nature bien merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Secrétaire général les bateaux vont
avoir du mal pour entrer dans les ports
français à partir de demain la grève des
équipages des remorqueurs qui avait
débuté il y a une semaine s'est étendue
à la totalité des ports français selon
la CGT les équipages des remorqueurs
entendent par cette extension du conflit
répondre à l'intervention des
remorqueurs de la Marine nationale dans
le port du Havre 11 jours après
l'enlèvement du baron hampin enquêteur
et ravisseur semblent maintenant
attendre un geste de part et d'autre les
enquêteurs espèrent découvrir un indice
ou provoquer une réaction la une
réaction qui leur permettrait de mettre
l'enquête vraiment au démarrage et puis
les gangsters eux attendent de leur
principale demande soit satisfaite
c'est-à-dire la levée des contrôles
policiers pour l'instant la police n'a
pas cédé 14000 policiers gendarmes et
CRS continuent de contrôler des dizaines
de mil de véhicules dans la région
parisienne et dans certains départements
de province cette présence de la police
a eu au moins un résultat la délinquence
a sérieusement diminuer depuis 10 jours
dans la région parisienne mais cela on
peut le craindre ne durera pas
d'ailleurs la police n'a pas les moyens
on le sait de maintenir un dispositif
semblable durant un temps très long
alors pour certains le temps de la peur
va revenir car la psychose de la
violence est une réalité en France
depuis maintenant quelques années
psychose car en réalité si l'on parle
beaucoup de la délinquence et si
celle-ci existe réellement elle est bien
moins forte qu'il y a quelques années ou
qu'au siècle dernier en
France
angoisse du parking cette scène de la
vie quotidienne fait peur car chaque
jour on nous parle des agressions dans
les souterrains la psychose est
crééeieol de les forcer
àadmirer envie de boir toutes leur
les et de disparaître en fumé
agression recherche de criminel
l'inquiétude apparaît et si l'on nous
répète que la violence augmente on le
croit c'est normal on la voit dans la
ville le sentiment d'insécurité nous
avons pu le mesurer par un certain
nombre d'indices s'est développé à
partir de 1973 surtout et il est en
croissance mais l'ensemble des crimes et
des délits qui sont portés la
connaissance de la police a baissé
dernier de 4 % par rapport aux années à
l'année précédente et jusqu'ici la
criminalité depuis 1973 s'est mise à
baisser alors vous voyez l'insécurité se
développe en même temps que la
criminalité
réelle diminue alors qu'est-ce qui peut
provoquer ce développement en ce moment
bien sûr vous le savez ce sont toutes
ces affaires très exceptionnel et c'est
aussi faut le dire la place que les mass
médias donnent à tout cela il sont le
reflet de quelque chose mais qui a une
conséquence émouvante et troublante et
en même temps il y a les barrages de
police partout tu peux prier qui tu
voudras j'aurai ta
peau tu
périras aucun dieu ne
m'apaisera j'aurai
laau tu
périras j'aurai ta mort
je suis
pour la presse est-elle responsable oui
répond le rapport perfide sur la
violence regardez bien ce graphique le
sentiment d'insécurité est très fort à
certaines périodes de l'année la hausse
de l'été s'explique par le
ralentissement de la vie politique
économique et sociale la place consacrée
alors par les médias à la délinquence
augmente la très grande insécurité
ressentie en novembre dernier est d à
l'énorme retentissement donné par la
presse à la piraterie
aérienne certains sondages jouent eux
aussi la carte de la
psychose un bon sondage c'est d'abord un
questionnaire honnête c'est-à-dire
objectif qui n'essaie pas d'influencer
les gens or tous les sondages sur la
violence sont des sondages difficiles à
réaliser si on demande aux gens est-ce
que vous avez peur de la mort ils
répondront oui si on leur demande à un
autre moment est-ce que demain vous avez
peur de mourir ils répondront non donc
actuellement vous pourriez faire un
sondage qui aurait pour conclusion que
que les gens n'ont pas peur bien sûr il
suffirait de poser d'autres questions si
on pouvait imaginer d'arrêter l'ensemble
des gens qui sont en voiture en leur
demandant est-ce que maintenant vous
pensez à l'accident de voiture il
répondrait non mais si avant qu'il ne
parte en voiture on leur demande
avez-vous peur de l'accident vous allez
prendre la route ils vont répondre oui
alors pourquoi pose-t-on à la population
des questions qui fait dire à cette
population qu'elle a peur et qu'elle
trouve que la violence est en recrees
sence c'est un problème d'information et
du système d'information on ne peut pas
imaginer un journal disant tout va bien
les Français n'ont pas peur le marché de
la peur c'est une bonne affaire en
matière d'alarme et de sécurité les
ventes augmentent de 20 % par an disons
que grosso modo nous arrivons à faire
des protections qui commencent aux
environs de 1500 francs pour finir à des
protections de porte qui se terminent à
6000 7000 8000 francs tout dépend de
Lapp et pour les alarmes en ce qui
concerne les alarmes nous avons des
alarmes simples qui commencent autour de
5000 francs entre 5000 et 7000 francs là
nous avons vraiment le bas de la gamme
en matière de
sécurité n'importe qui fait de l'alarme
maintenant et c'est une chose
particulièrement
dangereuse au fond s'il n'y avait pas de
voleur feriez faillite tout le monde
ferait faillite on fermerait la police
les avocats feraient faillite tout le
monde ferait faillite vous aussi
peut-être puisque vous ne seriez pas là
aujourd'hui
ouais mais ce chômage là n'est pas
encore pour demain le président Sadat a
quitté Le Caire aujourd'hui pour une
tournée d'une dizaine de jours première
étape de ce voyage Rabat où le président
égyptien aura des conversations avec le
roi Hassan 2 départ ensuite pour les
États-Unis où il rencontrera Jimmy
Carter durant le weekend et puis ce sera
l'Europe où le président anoir elsadad
s'entretiendra avec messieurs
giscardestin cagan et Schmid pendant ce
temps les négociateurs militaires
israéliens égyptiens achevaient la 2è
phase de leurs entretiens aucune date
n'a été fixée pour une prochaine
rencontre de la commission militaire
israélo-égyptienne et puis pendant ce
temps aussi à Alger le sommet de la
fermeté s'est ouvert dans la capitale
algérienne sans l'Irak et aussi sans le
colonel Kaddafi qui s'était fait
remplacé par le numéro 2 Libia le
commandant jaloud mais le colonel
Kaddafi est maintenant arrivé dans la
capitale algérienne et à 23h nous aurons
un premier contte-rendu de notre enyer
spécial à Alger Gérard Sebag en Tunisie
après les émeutes du 26 janvier des
centaines d'arrestations ont été opérées
dans la capitale et aussi en province le
nombre des émeutes est officiellement de
400 morts mais de sources officieuses le
chiffre dit-on pourrait atteindre le
millier il y a quelques heures monsieur
habi bachour le secrétaire général de
l'UGTT était suspendu de ses fonctions à
la tête de la centrale syndicale
tunisienne mesure pris ce matin par le
Bureau Exécutif de ce mouvement c'est un
coup très dur qui est porté là à
l'opposition tunisienne qui après les
événements contre ses
forces pour la première séance du
parlement depuis les émeutes du Jeudi
Noir les députés ont chanté l'hymne du
Destour
secoué par jours d'meut le régime du
président bourgiba pousse en effet
aujourd'hui un soupir de
soulagement à la tribune de l'Assemblée
le Premier ministre
ira accuse les responsables de l'Union
des travailleurs tunisiens le syndicat
devenu une véritable force d'opposition
d'avoir voulu étrangler son régime pas
de contestation dans les rangs de
l'Assemblée car tous les députés
appartiennent au parti unique
edira affirme ainsi que malgré ses
événements il poursuivra sa
politique successeur désigné du
président bourgiba il se présente
aujourd'hui comme le champion de la
continuité du régime il n' aura pas
d'après bourgibisme il aura le
bourgibisme qui continuera avec sa
tolérance avec sa perspective large sur
l'avenir avec ces réformes d'ordre
économique social politique tout cela
constitue l'éthique du bourgbisme auquel
certainement tous les Tunisiens y
tiennent en fait l'opposition au régime
se relèvera difficilement des émeutes
c'est ici dans la banlieue ouvrière de
Tunis qu'a commencé la révolte contre un
bureau de recette
fiscale dans cette zone industrielle la
majorité de la population vit avec le
salaire minimum de 500 francs par mois
et la centrale syndicale l'UGTT
recueille ici près de 100 % d'adhérents
mais aujourd'hui le syndicat est
décapité ses dirigeants arrêtés ceux des
militants qui n'ont pas voulu raller le
régime se sont regroupé autour de ce
journal l'opinion un hebdomadaire que le
gouvernement vient d'autoriser à
paraître et qui tire déjà à 40000
exemplaires depuis
longtemps nous avons demander nous avons
fait des propositions pour changer le
système politique tout à fait récemment
il y a il y a 3 mois de
cela je suis allé voir le Président
bourgiba je lui ai dit attention
l'équilibre actuel est un équilibre
fragile ne vous méprenez pas il faut
faire quelque chose pour assurer
garantir les conditions de stabilité
durable nous avons proposé notre Pact
national les Tunisiens sont à présent
partagés dans ce quartier populaire de
la meddina par exemple plus de la moitié
des habitants ont soutenu les
manifestants tout le monde reconnaît la
grandeur passé de bourgiba le combattant
suprême mais chacun demande une
meilleure justice sociale on veut mieux
vivre et on le fait savoir mais même
après ses émeutes bourgiba ne s'est pas
adressé au
tunisiens à 74 ans le combattant suprême
qui vient de se faire ériger une statue
en plein cœur de Tunis ne veut pas de
changement rad
et c'est à présent l'armée qui doit
défendre le régime en place mais elle
pourrait un jour être tentée par le
pouvoir il y a un an tout le monde
l'appelait la raffinerie du centre de
Paris mais a-t-on déjà vu une raffinerie
visitée en un an par plus de 6 millions
de personnes c'est donc que le Centre
Georges Pompidou autrement dit le musée
beauourg c'est aussi autre chose c'est
un musée certes mais un musée vivant qui
suscite parfois l'admiration souvent le
sarcasme mais jamais l'indifférence cela
signifie qu'après un an d'existence le
but est atteint on ne peut peut-être pas
encore le dire car sur les 6 millions de
visiteurs combien n'y remettront jamais
les pieds nul ne le sa mais ce que l'on
sait c'est que parmi ces visiteurs
nombreux étaient ceux qui entrai pour la
première fois dans un musée qui faisait
ainsi connaissance avec une certaine
culture celle de l'art contemporain dont
il se sentait exclu depuis des années et
des années beauour n'est pas amusé comme
les autres chacun le voit à sa manière
c'est peut-être pour cela le seul musée
populaire de
France
il y a un mystère bobour son public pour
l'expliquer on a fait appel aux
statistiques mais les chiffres
n'évoquent rien il s'agit de
regarder ici tout est spectacle le plus
impressionnant est celui de la foule des
dimanches on y voit des jeunes des
étrangers des provinaux mais surtout la
grande masse des parisien avec un solide
appétit de
culture
on s'en met plein la bouche plein les
yeux plein les
doigts au musée à l'insu des gardiens on
effleure on touche on mesure on
palpe
elle a maigri ou quoi elle a maigri
elle a gros elle est plutôt
musclée
pr
c m des for c'est c'est ce qu's emmène
près à la refondre des trucs comme ça B
mais c'est absolument dégueulasse mon
trucs le regard appelle le contact qui
nous
explique ce qui qui nous donne le sens
Mo ami-jambe de la foule des badoau les
enfants qui révèlent les émotions des
parents
comment
bobour fascine au point de susciter la
rêverie une rêverie collective au rythme
de la promenade et des
escalateurs on y écoute la ville la
ville qui vient se frotter à l'art
contemporain
en sport à garmich ce matin le Suédois
Ingemar Stenmark a remporté le
championnat du monde de ski en slalom
géant le litenstein a réussi à un très
beau tir groupé accaparant les deux
autres médailles la médaille d'argent et
la médaille de bronze de cette course
avec Andreas venzel second et Nil
fromelt 3e le premier français Gilles
maega est arrivé 22e il y avait
également un tierc aujourd'hui le tierc
il fallait jouer le 3 le 15 et le 5 pour
l'emporter vous voyez les rapports 4653
3 franc 50 pour 5 francs dans l'ordre et
901 francs pour 5 francs toujours dans
un ordre
différent les prévisions de la météo
pour demain du pas decaléis à l'Alsace
et aux Alpes nombreuses averses le matin
qui donneront de la pluie en pleine et
de la neige en montagne et qui seront
accompagné de violentes rafales de vent
dans l'ouest et le sud-ouest des gelées
matinales le temps se couvrira sur ces
régions en cours de journée ailleurs un
ciel variable avec quelques averses des
éclaircis un peu plus importantes près
de la Méditerranée mais avec en
contrepartie du mistral et de la
tramontane voilà la dernière édition de
ce journal vous sera présentée aux
alentours de 23h 23h05 par Noël Mamère
il est temps pour moi de prendre congé
je vous souhaite donc de passer une très
bonne fin de soirée bonsoir à
demain